- It's an election year,
which means we're all about
to go through a breakup.
And an eight year relationship
is always hard to get over.
Oh, well not always.
(audience laughs)
Go away.
I'm talking about Obama.
We're not ready to say goodbye
yet,
but all we can do is cope.
So here are my tips for
dealing with a breakup.
Okay, first get rid of
everything
that reminds you of Obama,
including those dad jeans,
that Portuguese water dog
poster,
and Joe Biden.
(audience laughs)
I'm sorry, Joe, bye.
And seriously, don't stalk
his social media accounts.
I assure you, he's not up.
And don't drive by his house,
he's moving, all right?
Now I know there's always
gonna be those songs
that remind you of him like this
one.
("Hail to the Chief" by James
Sanderson)
That's our song you guys, turn
it off,
turn if off, (sobs) I can't take
it.
He's perfect, it's like he
didn't do anything wrong.
All I can think about is
that sweet perfect jump shot,
you hunky angel of a man, oh!
- [Barack] I'm not gonna be
humiliated.
- Oh Jesus, goddamn it.
He's the most fuckable
president we'll ever have.
(audience laughs)
Think about it.
Like tell me you wouldn't fuck
this guy.
Ah, pull yourself together, pull
it,
let's, come on, it's time to
move on.
You know, maybe this is the
right time
to like experiment with
something new,
like a woman or a rotting
bag of baby carrots.
I don't know.
(audience laughs and applauds)
Please.
I refuse to show Donald Trump's
face if I don't have to.
I'm not Wolf Blitzer, yet.
You'll need to tune in next time
for that,
but this week on Not Safe
I head down to a Trump rally
and ask his supporters if
he's the right candidate
to make America horny again.
Tune in Tuesday at 10:30pm to
find out.
(audience cheers and applauds)